hey YouTube before I start this episode
you guys have been bullshitting way too
many of you were watching the show
taking all the value for free and giving
me dick in comments I need to comment
today do it on this episode we talk
about my 20s desktop in 20 years and if
it's OK for celebrities to [ __ ] you
[Music]
[Music]
Guerry be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 112 of
the askgaryvee show super pumped here
today looks like we're organizing for an
all hands-on meeting that i don't have
to run which feels very good that's the
maturity of the company itself Big Ups
to everybody who is supporting this show
I want you to know vaynernation I'm
making this very black-and-white this
episode would never have happened 35 40
60 days ago unlike in meetings right now
I should be in a meeting right the
second I'm real tight right now I have
to go to can for the big advertising
festival literally this was exactly I
see everybody shaking her head you don't
have cameras on them this was exactly
the kind of episodes that were not
happening 60 90 120 days ago because
running companies is what I do and this
would get trumped but your enormous
word-of-mouth passing on the show
getting me new people
Instagram explosion Facebook tagging
each other YouTube I want to talk to you
I just realize how many of you are
watching on YouTube if you don't leave a
comment here I'm gonna be pissed
way more watching than commenting you're
getting lazy on me YouTube step up but I
want you all to know you get this show
strictly because of the momentum India
the momentum Stefan the momentum we are
creating India let's get into the show
yes for sure let's go Yul asks in your
mid-20s do you wish you had done more
things or focused more on one thing
great question you in my mid 20s I
focused on one thing actually was
completely all in on Wine Library there
was nothing else I've said in this show
before then I wish I went out and hooked
up with some more chicks and had some
fun that was one thing I wish I did
because I was so you want to talk about
being focused on one thing as a 20 year
old guy in my 20s it's actually
uncomfortable how focused I was on the
hustle and building the infrastructure
of my career you know I think at some
level when you look back
you're always you know I'm equally this
is where I'm like a paradox I'm equally
completely pumped because look how happy
I am and those were great times I'm
happy now like I would never change
anything at the same token you're always
looking back at me like goddamn I could
have done this I could have done that
you I'm pretty happy with the way things
have played out I don't like to play
Monday Morning Quarterback with my life
but I think it's it served me well I
learned real foundational skills of how
to run a company it's why I'm hyper
focused and why I'm capable now to run a
company while doing a couple more things
because I know what it takes which is
serious focus but once in a while you
jump in and do a show when you didn't
have to and and so that's where I'm at
with that thanks for a question you'll
Sam asks you always say that people pay
for services that give time what area
needs a time-saving business like an
uber Sam I don't know all of them for
example I would absolutely pay for my
clone to do this show right now so I
could be in the meeting that I really
have to be in right obviously that's a
little far-fetched in a little far away
but I think there's a ton of things I
think I would pay a lot of money right
now to have somebody on demand do
certain things for my grandma and her
retirement home right
picking up my cleaner so obviously
there's the post mates and people that
are saving time but I actually think
I've got a good one for you I'm gonna go
deep here a little bit even though I'm
in a little bit of a rush and clearly
I'm talking a little faster than normal
so all of you so for all of you that are
listening to this on 2x speed let's for
X this [ __ ] here we go when Facebook
really hit and myspace was still being
like kind of leader everybody started
creating these social networks right
social networks every I would have
invested in the baseball social network
the gardening social network the goth
museum social network like I'm kidding I
really really the niches were happening
right but it turned out to be hindsight
was we only needed one social network I
actually think that was versus gonna
happen for the time saving economy
meaning there's post meets and arose all
these kind of like we do everything I
actually think this is gonna be a space
where people win on nisha out so like a
drycleaner pickup thing ship sh Y P I'm
obsessed with we got a little money
our last fund disclosure for ship not on
that a lot but boy do I love them
because nobody wants to go to the post
office so I think that's an incredible
one you know I think there's a look I'll
give you one like like I don't want to
go shopping like come to me here at
Vayner let me put on some shoes and
pants real fast five minutes and I'm out
I will buy so much more so personal
shopping coming here big one there's
instacart so there's food literally
anything you do any like question of the
day list two things that you do that you
hate doing that's in play because you
hate doing it because you'd rather be
doing something else and that's where
the time arbitrage is and so you know
gardening hanging pictures in your house
like babe like that just everything I
just everything is gonna be armed
anything a human doesn't want to do is
in play I'm trying to think of one more
good example anybody got one that popped
to their mind
no but the lot launches oh no no no no
get back to it come on
no there's nothing that's a singular app
right now that literal you press a
button and you give somebody a bag like
like how many you don't even put it back
how about they walk into your house and
take your pile because we're living in a
more open society where Trust is a real
play we're letting people stay in our oh
wait a minute you're telling me that
somebody wouldn't leave their door open
and let and just put a pile of this is
what I would do put a pile of clothes in
the front and somebody could come with
the key and get it in a world where air
being me you're letting people stay in
your home trust is on the rise my
friends cuz transparency is on the rise
getting harder to hide and do the wrong
thing very very interesting times Kobe
the Kobe okay hope you what are you at
no I see right that was a bad yeah there
was no reason to go to India there miss
play by you can I have a Miss play D
Rock logo the rock miss play you rock
miss play alright
Kobe asks is it okay for celebs to
promote products on Instagram without
telling their audience they get paid for
it
no and I'm sure it can happen you know
like I listen we invest there's so many
things I'm always scared like talking
about products and apps that we're in
the go
ship right now right but is it okay
absolutely not
like that why in the world would that be
okay India like I don't see and I don't
see yeah I wanted to put on the show
because I want to put the line of sand
like because people oh I know how to put
in a show cuz people like hey does
Pinterest pay Gary to say it's good I
mean are you crazy like like I mean like
I haven't told you much money I've tied
up in Twitter as I sit here on every
show saying it's crap it's losing it's
getting worse like like absolutely your
word is always your most valuable asset
and celebrities that think they can
trick their fans are gonna be in for a
rude awakening in the long tail of their
career it's an insane play it has no
value it's it's it's stupid
it happened look like look I try to
disclose our investments all the time of
course you're a human something but
knowingly non disclosing really this is
great and like that's insanity insanity
so also probably be massively illegal as
like the laws catch up to full
disclosure and things of that nature I'm
at that part
so no I don't think it's okay Oh Mike
yeah social media examiner hey Gary Mike
Stelzner social media examiner my
question for you is podcast versus video
yeah which one has been more effective
for you I know that you have a video
show and you also have an ask Gary
podcast and I'm just curious which one
has been more effective which one has
more listeners if you're recommending
that somebody gets started should they
do the video should they do the podcast
should they do both I'd love to hear
your thoughts thanks Mike video has been
more effective for me because this is a
video first show and then the podcast is
just a transcribe for this so you know
obviously for this show it's been video
so many of the people are winning more
on podcast because they either not doing
the video or they're not as good at
video I think I'm better in video than
podcast form I'm also making the format
for this obviously if I made this for
audio I would have a different play I
did wine and web on Sirius for nine
months where that was made for audio it
was a different show a different format
I interviewed people obviously that's
what so much of a podcast right now are
really if you think about it I don't
want to be disrespectful to podcasts
I've big ups for all the
Podcast I want to be on them when I'm
promoting stuff so I don't want to get
into the 30 territory here but these
podcasts are completely reliant on
guests like how do you keep it fresh
otherwise right you know I'm I'm I'm so
I'm proud of being able to keep it fresh
one-man show kind of thing well
obviously you characters and so and so I
think that for me it's been video I
think that the context and the format
that you're creating for matters so I
think podcasts that are filming
themselves doing the podcast and there's
video won't do as well on video cuz
that's secondary here audio is secondary
but uh so that's it that's in that
result might but I think the right pop
right platform is the right platform for
you I think that I have the charisma and
the antics and the control of the camera
that very few have which is why I've had
two successful video shows and so I
think I'm an anomaly there and I'm gonna
milk that because that has extraordinary
value but uh but there's plenty of other
people who crush it cuz their voice is
deep my voice stinks I mean think about
how many great voices there are and so
like you know if you're rolling deep and
you know you could be some stop so I
think you got to pick your medium and
that's the same with social networks are
you better at snapchat Twitter Facebook
gotta find an you gotta respect the
context of the platform Sean asks will
Desktop exist in 20 years are we talking
desktop computers you think right are we
touch our we including this artifact
yeah yes this I do you know it's in 20
years I mean you know I really want to
believe that will be like working on
everything is smart definitely not the
way we think about it now like this is
an artifact I mean I didn't think of
laptops weirdly artifact I mean take my
laptop home last night I was at my
in-laws home going back there tonight
but I had a couple hours to work and I
was able to do it on my phone that was
unheard of for me a year ago so if I'm
involving and evolving into that way I
think the whole rest of the market will
I definitely a hundred percent not the
way we're at well there'd be something
in between this and an iPad I do think
there's some screening needs but I'm not
even sure if I'm thinking about it right
in a twenty year window that's so far
out I mean is the screen just right
right here I mean I think that's very
feasible
I definitely I'm calm
and saying the screens right here on
this table so no answer's no but I could
be wrong I can't wait to watch this in
20 years to a remember how great I
looked at this time in my life and B to
see if I was right I asked the question
of the day I was already done in there
uh there was a good show
I liked that show fast and furious then
I just get sued you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]
jab
[Music]